-My next guest is the former
mayor of South Bend, Indiana,
a New York Times best-selling
author, and the nominee
for United States
Secretary of Transportation.
It's my pleasure to welcome back
to the show
Mayor Pete Buttigieg!
Hey, Mayor Pete,
thank you so much
for being on our show
and coming back.
You're in Washington, D.C.,
right now
because you attended the --
President Biden's
inauguration today.
You were the first person I saw
this morning to enter almost.
How did it feel to be there?
-You know, it was amazing.
It was moving.
It was reassuring
to be on those Capitol steps
where just two weeks earlier,
we'd seen those
horrifying images
of a mob seeking
to take over the Capitol.
What we saw today
was one of the most important
and oldest rituals
in American democracy,
that transfer of power.
And I think for a lot of us,
things that maybe
we used to think of as boring
or take for granted, you know,
on a day like this,
at a time like this,
actually meant a lot,
that there was
that -- that continuity.
The president, I thought,
gave a great speech.
There were these
musical performances,
Garth Brooks, J.Lo, Gaga,
and also this amazing poet,
Amanda Gorman,
who really
set the tone for the day.
So it was a great day.
-She was amazing.
I saw when you first --
You were one of the first people
to get there,
and I know you probably can't,
being where you are
and your stature,
but I couldn't help but get
emotional watching everything.
Just even everyone just coming,
the way that the Capitol
was decorated,
it made me so patriotic
and so proud,
and just seeing the flag flying,
and I go yes. It made me so --
It was like, I felt like
I was, you know, in a George
M. Cohan song or something.
-Yeah, you know, I didn't used
to care about symbols so much.
especially when I was
first getting involved
in public service
when I was mayor.
I cared about policy. I cared
about getting things done,
and events didn't mean
as much to me.
But I think just with everything
we've been through as a country,
we realize that
those symbols matters.
The continuity of it matters,
the kind of process
that we go through,
because it reminds us
of the stability of the country.
It reminds us
what we're trying to protect
when we protect
American democracy.
-What do you think is next
for President Biden
and how he's going
to get the country to unite?
-Well, I think we saw in his
speech
that he's calling out
to everybody.
He's making clear he wants to be
a president for everyone,
whether you voted for him
or not.
But I think in the long run, the
best way to unite the country
will be to deliver results.
I know that's gonna
be his focus.
The best way I think to bring
people together is to make sure
that life in this country
gets better,
that our economy is strong,
that there's safety,
that there's justice and equity.
And there's a ton of work
starting right away,
and it really starts of course
with defeating the pandemic.
So it was great that
even before the inauguration,
as president-elect, he laid out
the first steps of that plan.
Now as president, he's already
working to deliver them,
and I'm excited to be part
of the team to make that happen.
-I don't know if I'll be able
to call you Mayor Pete anymore,
because hopefully,
tomorrow you will be confirmed
for the role of
Secretary of Transportation.
This is a historic nomination.
You'll be the first
Millennial cabinet member,
and you'll also be
the first openly gay person
to serve in a cabinet position.
What does that all mean to you,
or have you even
thought about it?
-Yeah, it means a lot.
You know, I can remember
being in high school
watching on the news
when President Clinton nominated
someone to be an ambassador
who didn't even get the chance
to get a vote in the Senate
because he was gay.
And it sent a message.
At that age,
I hadn't really thought
that I would be serving
in public service like I am now,
but it sent a message, you know,
not only that gay people might
be denied a chance to serve
but also denied
a chance to belong.
So the fact
that 20-some years later,
tomorrow, I'll go
before a committee
and hopefully receive a vote
that will make it possible
once the confirmation
vote comes up
to become a confirmed
cabinet member --
I just hope that that
sends a different, better,
opposite message to some kid
who's watching right now,
that you have every right
to belong, every right to serve,
every right
to be part of this country.
-Four years from now,
what do you hope
that you will have accomplished
in the role?
-You know, I'd love to be able
to look back
on a tenure as secretary
and say first of all
that travel was and remains safe
for workers and for travelers,
but also above and beyond that,
that America restored
its leadership role
when it came to infrastructure.
We've fallen behind.
We've been expected to tolerate
roads and bridges
falling into disrepair,
passenger rail being way behind
what our fellow --
our, you know, counterparts,
citizens in other countries
are able to enjoy,
just a lot of things
where we've settled for less,
and I think now is a chance
to do something about that.
I'd love to look back
on these years and say
this was when electric vehicles
became much more widely adopted
and the possibilities there
with technology
around electric vehicles,
around automated vehicles if we
can get the safety part right,
and a whole bunch of other
things that are coming
could allow us to say that
America became better prepared
for the climate crisis,
more just,
and more economically sound
because we did what we had to do
when it came to infrastructure.
I know it's seen as
kind of a nerdy topic sometimes.
But I think it's one of
the most interesting things
that is before
the administration right now,
and I'm really excited
to do my part.
-Good luck tomorrow, and
anything we can do to help --
We'd love to have you
back on the show whenever.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
Mayor Pete Buttigieg.